des chercheurs strasbourgeois devant
leurs laboratoires pour s'opposer à sa
relocalisation ce jeudi dans la capitale
alsacienne ils étaient une quarantaine
contre la fermeture du site
les personnes particulièrement menacées
par ce transfert
les 54 cdi et la vingtaine de cdd et
intérimaires spécialisé dans la
recherche contre le cancer
ce laboratoire pourrait être transféré à
vitry sur seine en région parisienne un
changement qui pourrait s'accompagner de
la suppression de près de 3 164 postes
chez sanofi principalement dans la
recherche
d'après les syndicats en manifeste parce
que au mois de juin nous avons eu des
annonces qui nous disait que le centre
de strasbourg
les sur le centre de strasbourg les
passes allaient être transférés sur le
site d'excellence immunologie de vitry
sur seine
mais nous ce qu'on comprend s'il n'est
pas ce sont transférés à vitry le comité
social et économique qui a eu lieu ce
jeudi à vitry sur seine avait pour but
de faire le point sur le sort du site
strasbourgeois
cette restructuration ne laisse aucune
marge de manoeuvre aux salariés et peu
d'entre eux sont en mesure d'aller vivre
en région parisienne l'inquiétude est
palpable par cette mobilité par cette
fermeture du site programmée
parce que même si aujourd'hui le terme
de fermeture de site n'est pas
directement employés on se retrouve avec
une perte d'expertisé dans un domaine
aujourd'hui critique qui est en risque
de disparaître
ici on est vraiment dans le domaine de
la recherche c'est à dire que ces
transferts en régime vers la région
parisienne font partie intégrante du
plan des 400 suppressions de postes en
recherche en juin 2020 le géant
pharmaceutique avait annoncé la
suppression de 1700 emplois à travers
toute l'europe ces dernières années
plusieurs grands groupes tels que sanofi
cherchent à externaliser leurs activités
en recherche principalement en raison
des coûts élevés